morning all he says there is no light
at the end of the tunnel today the
chancellor rishi sunak will reveal his
budget
and exactly how he plans to continue
protecting jobs and incomes
through the pandemic as we begin to see
an ease out of lockdown he'll be
briefing mps this lunch time at 12 30
but we do know some of what's ahead for
us let's take you through
the bits that we do know uh the
chancellor of course extending the
furlough scheme
which has protected around 11 million
workers so far
until at least the end of september 600
000 more people are expected to be given
assistance
including newly self-employed people
who'd previously missed out
as access to government grants is
widened
but the big question is whether the
chancellor will choose to pay for those
measures and
whether taxes will have to rise if so
when will that happen our deputy
political editor sam coats
has this money's first report this is
the budget chancellor rishi sunak
renewing his vow to do
whatever it takes for business and the
country
promising to use fiscal firepower to
protect jobs and livelihoods in the
budget
obviously i can't tell you exactly
what's in there right now
but key details we know furlough
extended in full until the end of july
and then wound down entirely at the end
of september
600 000 more people eligible for grants
for the self-employed for business
owners like
james mintram who owns an animal
sanctuary in lincolnshire
and currently has all his staff on
furlough an extension to the scheme will
save
jobs in his firm it's fantastic news
for a small business like us and a
rescue sanctuary whose finances have
been
absolutely wiped out it means we can
bring back
staff gradually because we just don't
have the finances to bring everyone back
in one hit we can bring them back
gradually
as hopefully revenue comes back into the
site and for those stuff
we can't bring in straight away it's
going to ensure the survival of their
job
on the chancellor's home turf richmond
in yorkshire
constituents weren't sure whether they
wanted to go with the flow of the
potential tax risers
we do need to raise the money somehow to
keep the country going no
not at all no there's too many people on
furlough and there's just not enough
money coming into poor households he's
got to put some taxes up at some time
whether it's now or october
i don't know whether in yorkshire almost
five hours away in whitehall the same
questions will have been asked about how
to fill a borrowing black hole
when and how perhaps the trickiest
conundrum of all
all the mood music i'm hearing indicates
there's no
uh appetite for so-called austerity
which means living within one's means
really
and so i will be surprised if down the
road maybe not
this year maybe not even next year but i
think we're bound to see some tax
increases
uh down the road and i think you have to
grasp the metal
all will be revealed today in the
commons chamber with a new first
a budget with a sign language
interpreter the speaker of the house of
commons touring the studios
where commons proceedings are turned
into tv the speaker also calling on the
chancellor to make announcements to mps
before spending time briefing the media
at a press conference
tradition matters and it's important
that people hear it on the floor of the
house
not briefing newspapers before and
certainly not dashing off afterwards
to tell them how good they were we will
judge that ourselves by doing it live in
the comments
unflustered and admired that's the story
the treasury's own pictures tell
but can a tax rising chancellor remain
popular
sam coates sky news
uh well let's pick up on those thoughts
with the former treasury minister simon
clark
on the program representing the
government today mr clark great to have
you on the programme um and of course
there are any number of questions about
particular policies that we
may see announced later on today some of
which you may well not want to answer
before we get to those
just in terms of this emerging view that
we at some point need to
to balance the books viewing government
spending you know as akin to household
spending do you think that that's a
decent analogy
i do i think in the end responsible and
honest management of the public finances
really matters actually and being
totally upfront with the british people
about the choices that we face at this
budget because
we have been borrowing at what are
effectively wartime levels over the last
year and our response to coronavirus
has cost the exchequer about 280 billion
pounds and
we can't continue at that rate obviously
we we do need a chance that i'm sure
will continue to support
the economy and we've already heard the
extension of furlough for example in
that regard
over these last months of the pandemic
but we also need to make sure that we're
in a position where on the other side of
this
we have control of the public finances
that really
really matters in terms of giving both
this chance
and future chances all the options they
need for any future scenarios that arise
if you think back to the 2010s
uh when we had to make tough choices
then to get the public finances back
together
that allowed us to make this response to
coronavirus in 2020 and into this year
if you don't have strong public finances
you are vulnerable to external shots
sure that is true and of course two key
differences between the situation in
2010 and now
2010 followed on from you know the
global crash that's not the situation
we're in at the moment
and also i mean in terms of servicing at
these debts yet they aren't the figures
are eye-watering 450 billion pounds
worth of debt
but in terms of paying the interest on
those debt like as a percentage of you
know
the country's revenues it is at a
historic low we could afford
to borrow more this morning we're very
fortunate the borrowing rates
are really low at the moment and that is
one of the reasons uh that
this response has been possible but you
can't assume that those rates remain low
in perpetuity we're talking about
5-10 trillion 15-year terms and
government bonds and the majority of the
money that we have borrowed the
overwhelming majority of money that we
have borrowed were borrowed from the
bank of england which i think we own
but if i mean literally a one percent
rise in the cost of government borrowing
would put
up uh the cost to the taxpayer each year
by the end of this parliament by 25
billion pounds that's
a huge sum of money would rip a great
hole in the government finances
if you don't have this this plan to
restore control gradually i'm sure
that's what the chancellor is going to
do today we're not talking about some
some wave of tax rises that's going to
choke growth we are talking however
about
a plan that balances strong ongoing
support for the economy
with our leveling up agenda but also
with the beginnings of restoring
credibility to the public finances and i
think you know that is a really
important signal to send both to
investors
but also to the public that we are going
to live uh within our means once more
over the course of you know a reasonable
time horizon and we're going to start
that journey today
just in terms of that which we're
expecting to hear from the chancellor
well we know that this one is coming the
the furlough scheme is to be extended
uh until september at the same time the
roadmap is laid out
that it takes us to the end of june all
of which rather suggests
that we could be seeing companies a
number of companies
still putting staff on furlough on the
other side of the summer
well i mean look i think it's important
we have a thorough scheme which gives
companies a full range of options and
we'll and we start to see
as the chances were set out uh the
thurgood scheme being tapered down
from july so that in august uh your
employers are playing more i think it's
it it is
important that we have that element of
flex within the systems
so that if there is any slippage
obviously we hope there isn't the road
map is clear that
we i understand that but you know we
have a particularly
going on here we have a degree of
messaging going on here
let me explain why i'm making the point
you know on the one hand we have a
furlough scheme that is running until
september
you know a couple of days ago with the
prime minister talking about lining up
the pints
for the football this summer well i
think we all
absolutely hope and intend uh to be to
be having a very normal
uh summer and that is what the road map
sets out to a series of stage steps but
we've always been clear that
you know there is there is a degree
whereby we don't have full control of
events do we
if the virus takes an extra twist if if
for any reason
uh things change beyond what the road
map uh
sets out and clearly if anything one
hopes that things may go
may go even better than than planned and
actually
if anything you know we're in a
situation where our war against the
virus has been won
even faster than we dared to hope but if
i
if i think everyone would support
everyone in favor
i think everyone is in favor of that
taking place but but just in terms of
the decision on on extending the
furlough
i mean people have been asking business
owners have been asking for clarity on
this not just for the past few days
but for the past couple of months you
know we were told we can't make any
announcements
ahead of the budget and truth and once
again
we have a situation in which ahead of
the budget
we find out about furlough why has there
been this delay
on something which business owners have
been crying out for and we can't say
you have to wait until the chancellor
gets to the dispatch box because clearly
we haven't had to wait for the
chancellor to get to the dispatch box
well it's been clear uh since the autumn
that furlough would run until uh the end
of
april and we we we've always wanted to
make sure that we provide
the maximum uh degree of assurance to
business that we can
this is this is a budget which sets out
the entire
uh set of policies for the period
through to the end of the pandemic and i
think it is important that it's
it's situated as part of that suite of
policies designed
not only to see us through these next
six months
where covert is going to be very much a
big factor in our lives but also clearly
looking ahead to that longer term
recovery and how we intend
over time to build that better and start
to also get our public finances back
into
into good order but just in terms of
that which we're hearing from from the
speaker so lindsey hoyle in sam coates
report there i mean he's suggesting that
perhaps the chancellor needs
a little bit of a wrap on the knuckles
once again briefing the papers
briefing the public before briefing
parliamentarians who's got the right
approach in all of this mr sunak uh or
sir lindsay
well i know that the chancellor has the
utmost respect for parliament as we all
want to be demonstrating it this morning
without the city
no i i'm absolutely confident that that
the chancellor has observed audrey
propriety and obviously he'll be setting
out the full suite of budget policies uh
on the floor of the house uh at
lunchtime and that's
that's as it should be i mean it is
obviously the case
and as with all batches occasional
headline announcements and furlough
being one of them
will will will come out in the hours
leading up to them but
the great the overwhelming majority of
this budget remains absolutely as it
should be
to be heard by the house of commons uh
and and the nation
just after 12 o'clock a huge day in
british politics
as we said at the the very beginning of
this program not least of course that
which would just be discussing the
budget but also
events taking place in and around at the
scottish parliament at nicholas sturgeon
under a considerable amount of pressure
at the moment should the first minister
uh resign from her post
if it is proved either that she lied
or indeed that she broke them in a
stereo code
well these are really very serious
allegations about
uh nicholas sturgeon i think the
scottish parliament obviously has got a
massive day
in its own history today with it with
the inquiry
it's not for me to pre-judge what what
decisions uh scottish parliament
may take and i'm not asking you to
inquire and i'm not asking you to do so
it is
it is a fairly straightforward point
which you can answer right now if the
first minister is shown to have lied or
broken the ministerial code
should she resign well it would be my
view that any minister
uh in any parliament who found
themselves in that situation would would
be in an untenable position and so yes
i think it would solve your colleagues
in the conservative party
no i i think i think i think that the
degree of the allegations
is extremely serious about admitted
sturgeon it clearly is if we look at the
the thrust of these allegations they are
they are very serious they do need to be
judged by the scottish parliamentary
inquiry today but in principle clearly
uh serious breaches multiple serious
breaches of the ministerial code
does put any minister in an unviable
situation and that is and that is the
scenario
which may have occurred in scotland we
need to hear the evidence today before
judging that
i i i will say it again i mean there
will be a number of people
shouting at the screen this morning now
what about pretty patel
what about any other number of cabinet
ministers
working in whitehall who if not in
technical breach of the ministerial code
have
certainly either made a huge
catastrophic mistake
or been forced into an embarrassing
u-turn i mean those things that's fine
you can stay in post but
you know pretty patel and another
breaches of the ministerial code well
that that's when we should be seeking
resignation
now i think i think the the the the
seriousness of the allegations
which are in front of the holyrood
committee today are of a different order
of magnitude to anything i can recall
uh in recent times in westminster they
are a very
uh really a very very comprehensive and
serious set of
uh of concerns about about the conduct
of the scottish government
and the first minister in this regard
and i do think they need to be regarded
with the utmost seriousness
obviously it is important we hear uh the
evidence that's given today but it is a
very concerning situation and it's
a real testing moment i think for the
scottish
the scottish parliament in terms of its
ability to exercise
uh control and scrutiny and so it will
be a very important day in terms of
uh the development of that parliament
end of devolution
uh simon clark really good to see you
this morning thank you uh for filling in
for the government ministers good to
have you on the show
uh well let's dwell on our conversation
uh with simon clark
uh political correspondent tom rayner is
braving the fog and the cold and downing
street for us this morning uh tom you
were listening in
to the conversation with mr clark
that's right neil i mean we didn't get
the minister setting out
any new details ahead of the budget but
i think we definitely got him setting
out the tone of what we can expect from
that budget talking about the need
for honest management of the public
finances and i think that word
honest chimes with what we heard from
the chancellor at the weekend saying
that he wanted to level with the british
public about the challenges
uh that the economy faces simon clark
saying that we cannot continue with
wartime levels of borrowing and push
back against the suggestion that
we as a country are not in a position to
need to worry about
uh the cost of borrowing at the moment
because of those low interest rates by
saying
uh that when there is a change in
interest rates with that amount of
uh debt you are very vulnerable to
external threats but i think the
comment that stood out most neil
particularly given the fact that simon
clark was
suggesting that there is going to be
some difficult
messages from the chancellor is the line
where he said that he's not that we're
not talking about some wave of tax rises
that is going to slow growth
but we are going to live within our
means once more starting that journey
today so i think there you see an
indication that what we are not going to
see
is any immediate increases to income tax
or corporation tax even perhaps but
signaling
that tax rises are coming down the line
tom many thanks indeed and we will have
full coverage of the budget that's
starting uh from 12 30
this afternoon here on sky news across
all the platforms mobile
telly whatever you see the logo
at will in uh well a little less than
two hours time the first minister of
scotland nicholas sturgeon
will be appearing at the inquiry looking
at allegations of mishandling of
harassment complaints
against her predecessor alex sam uh
we'll bring you her evidence live from
nine o'clock here on sky news as the
first minister
faces calls to resign ms sturgeon has of
course repeatedly denied
breaking the ministerial code she's just
left her home in glasgow these the very
latest pictures
morning first minister did you break the
ministry of food
uh nice guys james matthews takes a look
at the roads to the inquiry this morning
and what we might expect
from the first minister
if she didn't expect a hollywood
grilling before
nicola sturgeon will know
[Applause]
as darkness descended so did documents
to raise a resignation matter
certainly in the view of scotland's
conservatives who pursue a vote of no
confidence in the first minister
alex her government had released legal
advice
surrounding its defense of a court
action in 2018.
when alex salmon challenged its
investigation of harassment complaints
against him
and he won he'd said the scottish
government
were warned they'd lose but plowed on
regardless
at huge cost to the taxpayer in december
a blistering note from council to their
government clients read
suffice to say we have each experienced
extreme professional embarrassment
as a result of assurances which we've
been given
turning out to be false as a result of
the revelation of further documents
highly relevant yet undisclosed
then ten days later legal counsel deemed
the case in their words
unstateable and the government
subsequently conceded
i'm not sure how you get out of this uh
if you're nicola sturgeon
there is now clear evidence from
multiple sources
that she's lied to parliament that she
has misled the scottish people
it's very clear you can't just wipe away
the evidence that numerous witnesses
have had published
tuesday in parliament had seen the
politics of covet for nicola sturgeon
wednesday will witness the politics of
survival
before hollywood's harassment committee
well i've been in this parliament for 22
years
and i have never seen anything like this
it is quite extraordinary that the first
minister
is involved in the way that she is but
also there are huge questions to be
asked
of the entirety of the scottish
government as to what's happened
for its part the scottish government
says the legal advice was optimistic to
start
but became gradually less so over time
it says the release of the documents
rebuts what it calls false allegations a
spokesperson for nicola sturgeon
says she will address the issues raised
before hollywood's harassment committee
it might not be the biggest day of her
political career so far
but huge in shaping her career to come
james matthews sky news edinburgh
he was in his bed after dark he's up
before dawn our scotland correspondent
james matthews
has a very busy day ahead of him james
good to see you this morning um
let's focus shall we on on nicolas
sturgeon's appearance in front of the
inquiry what are the key questions
that people are demanding answers to
well the key questions are those to
which she's given general answers for
many months
even years neil i think the first
minister needs to come here with
a specific breakdown of specific
allegations that have been laid against
her
um you know as recently as last night of
course we had this legal advice coming
out
which does indicate the government were
warned there were concerns amongst
lawyers that
they were going to lose this key legal
action and yet they continued on
i might say with regard to that legal
advice there was a date
that that i was and many others would
have been looking for
at the 13th of november 2018
because that was the day that nicolas
sturgeon and others sat down with senior
council
and were advised about this judicial
review
and the question is where were the
documents from that meeting involving
the
the first minister where was the uh the
preparation note the consultation note
provided by
senior council so that's an open
question one i'm sure she will be asked
today she and she will be asked about
you know the key dates
april the second 2018. remember
that was the day she said she first
learned about complaints
against alex salmond there are others
who were in our company before that
who say they had discussions about these
complaints therefore
she knew before she told parliament she
did and these questions were
are indeed evidence to support that
contradict her account
uh that was piled on yesterday by two
very credible figures in the snp
duncan hamilton and kevin pringle they
said well yeah we
had conversations with somebody who had
conversations with her
and they were absolutely sure about what
they were saying that she knew earlier
than she told parliament so big
questions to be answered over many hours
here
at the hollywood parliament today
possibly into mid-afternoon
james thank you
about joining us now on the programme
henry mcleish the former first minister
of scotland uh mr cliff great to have
you on the program
this morning and of course you provide
perhaps a unique perspective on
on what the first minister is is going
through at the moment you
you yourself found yourself in a
position where you had to resign from
office
do you think the miss sturgeon's
position is actually terrible
well i think today's proceedings will um
explore that possibility
um i think that she's in some real
trouble
i think we have a situation where the
storm clouds are gathering
but i do think it's important that due
process um has its place in in in
politics
so therefore there's an inquiry uh in
the parliament there's an inquiry
pending on her
potential breach of the ministerial code
but no doubt about it you know
you know politics is a tough ugly
business and it will get no tougher no
uglier
than today's proceedings uh in the
parliament but on the other hand
she's a formidable performer she knows
her job
she has a lot of empathy with the
scottish people and they they with her
and so be interesting to see what
happens but my main concern is that
we see due process evolve and that's
what's going on today at hollywood
yeah one other thing that the first
minister currently has is the the
scottish greens at least in terms of the
the no
confidence vote put forward by douglas
ross and the scottish conservatives
that doesn't seem that it has got much
to run
look i think douglas ross has got to
watch i mean i think he's uh
he's a newcomer to the political scene i
think he's dancing to the tune of boris
johnson in london but it doesn't make
any sense to find
somebody guilty and and by due process
and treating with contempt the
parliamentary inquiry and also the
independent inquiry into her
potential breach of the code so i think
this is premature i think it's foolish
and i think the other parties have shown
much more restraint on the other hand
the
the other parties have shown serious
intent because i think neil
one of the issues here is we've got to
find the truth they can't both
be right and i think the truth is
becoming a very valuable commodity in
politics
and it's a classic
to react to it so i think put douglas
ross on scientists now
and concentrate on the committee
inquiries and indeed
a very um uh difficult timetable between
now and parliament rising for the
election
certainly the pressure from ms
sturgeon's opponents led
to that legal advice uh ah ahead of the
uh the action taken against uh uh alex
salmon that that that legal advice
was put into the public domain yesterday
look many people will
suggest that when the lawyers are
telling you not to proceed with
something
you know there's a cost in the hundreds
of thousands you know they might better
have taken that advice but just in terms
of the ministerial code do you see it do
you perceive it
as a breach of the ministerial code not
to follow the legal advice that was
given to the government
i don't think that would be the
interpretation but i think the serious
issue is i mean you get advice
in government as ministers all the time
on a
large number of issues it is up to the
ministers to accept that advice or
reject it
i think what is important here is not so
much a breach of the ministerial code
but whether indeed the scottish
government then and and
involved themselves in some reckless
activity
knowing that the outcome would be rather
doubtful
and very very limited so it could be a
question of political judgment at stake
here rather than a breach of the
ministerial code but there are many
other aspects
of the issue to be raised by the
committee today but i think you're right
to identify you know all ministers must
act
lawfully at every opportunity
but not accepting legal advice in my
view is not a breach in itself
on the other hand it may be a judgment
over
um political behavior whether there's
political recklessness in here
or whether as alex salmon asserts there
are
underlying issues that are still to come
to the fore
regarding his and not only the the case
in court
but then the criminal case um where he
found
himself uh in severe difficulty but on
the other hand
was then um in a way
found not guilty on all the accounts
that were charged
just in terms of the of the the clash of
the personalities alex simons nicolas
sturgeon huge figures of course in
scotland huge figures in british
politics we
we've got to say i mean how much of this
is to do
with this emerging enmity between the
two of them and what do you think it
means
for the prospect of another independence
referendum
anytime soon well i think neil
as far as i'm concerned i mean this is
an unprecedented spot
in in scottish politics maybe even in uk
politics
there is such venom there's such vitriol
there is such hatred
and i think some of the comments of alex
salmon you know
there have been amazing
assertions and allegations made so that
i think is a is a scottish first it's
not something we're proud of
but it does show the degree to which
politics can slip
into a personal spot as well as a
political consequences
i think the other issue that you quite
rightly raised is how is this impacting
on public opinion
opinion polls are showing there's maybe
some slight movement in the polls
but nothing decisive and of course you
have the added question
of what this might do to the drive of
the s p for independence
i personally think that even if we
weren't having
um this uh inquiry in this spark between
them
there would be no um independence
referendum for two to three years
i mean boris johnson is not going to
allow one but more importantly
this is a massive distraction at the
present time in the sense that there's a
pandemic
people are still dying we have the
impact of brexit and the consequences
for a fishing industry
for example we have boris johnson's
behavior who is out in a way to throw as
many grenades
into scotland and then we've got
election of looming we simply don't need
this distraction that said it may well
be new
as we move forward so close to an
election that the court of public
opinion
might step in and the scottish public
might be able to make a judgment
on whether or not uh nicholas sturgeon
continues in office
or she demands office so very uncertain
time
and i think what we should do is focus
today on that inquiry
an enormous day for nicola sturgeon wait
for the outcome of the
the inquiry into the breach of
ministerial code once we've got all the
evidence
once the judgments have been made then
we as politicians and nx politicians
come to some um idea on the way forward
so
unsavory unedifying but sadly that's a
dimension of politics we're not going to
get rid of very quickly
you're telling me uh just in terms of of
the first minister
uh her personality the the the the stake
that she
has the foothold that she has in in
scottish politics can you conceive of
of any circumstances based on the
evidence that we've seen so far based on
the allegations that i've made
can you conceive of any circumstances in
which she would choose
to step down
not immediately in my mind because um
she's going to
today try and defend her position we'll
hear her case for the first time
and of course it will be under oath but
look there's a lot of pressure on her
it's quite clear over the last few days
this is beginning
to get to her which is not surprising
but it may well be
that you know the committee of inquiry
won't report before the election
the inquiry into the ministerial code
breach won't report before the election
and you've got a situation then where
she might carry on
and suggest that people of scotland will
decide her future
rather than have been done by the
scottish parliament there are so many
many
unknowns but i don't envy her position
but look
she's tough she's formidable um alex
salmond and nicolas durden
have been immense in terms of scottish
politics regardless of your political
persuasion and she will be briefed
she'll be aggressive and i think she's
promised to say she'll deal with the
issues that's alex salmond raised and
she added the caveat
and more so there may be fireworks neil
that we don't know about there may be
issues that she's going to reveal for
the first time
but look um in similar situations
politicians have to react
to what's ahead of them they've got to
deal with what's on their plate
but be in no doubt she is a formidable
operator
and anyone who writes her off as the
tories are doing just now
are being very foolish indeed henry
mcleish
great to have you on the program this
morning thanks for joining us thank you
very much
and we have uh full coverage of the
first minister's appearance
at the committee uh due to start at nine
o'clock this morning here on sky news
tends to be pretty prompt
uh but before all of that let's check in
with isabel
at the weather wall to find out how it's
looking this morning well just a couple
of hours ago it was looking well
very gray i couldn't see anything out
the windows london was covered in a
blanket fog
yeah we've got a similar story actually
this morning in fact the met office have
issued a yellow warning for fog across
the south east and east anglia neal but
there
is uh quite a foggy gray start for many
gloomy
doomy i don't know is that a word let's
take a look at the weather
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
frosty in the northwest this morning
with some fog there as well but that's
where we'll have the best of the
sunshine today eastern and central areas
and the south as well
seeing a mix of mist low cloud and fog
and the added bonus are some showers
that have been working their way up from
the south a few on the heavy side as
well as they continue to push their way
eastwards across southern britain
so as i said best of the sunshine across
northwestern areas not particularly warm
but temperatures they're getting up to
about eight
celsius under the persistent cloud
across some central and eastern parts
cold again probably only around four or
five degrees something like that but if
you see a bit of sunshine
across parts of the south and west i
think temperatures in a few spots could
get close to
say 12 celsius 54 fahrenheit as i said
though there will be showers they've
been coming up from the south overnight
pushing their way into
southwestern parts of britain and
they'll gradually migrate towards the
london area and into east anglia as we
head through tonight so some rain for
the southeast tonight elsewhere
again the return to mist fog and low
cloud with a change
to the north tomorrow we get rid of
early rain in the southeast elsewhere a
pretty cloudy day
but it will become increasingly chilly
but sunny in the north
later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you uh let's stick with our
top story the chancellor
rishi sunak due to deliver his budget
later today
our economics and data editor ed conway
has been delving into the country's
finances to get a picture
of what to expect it's budget day this
is the moment we learn the state of the
economy we learn what kind of taxes if
any the chancellor
is going to raise and indeed what he's
going to do to potentially balance the
books but does he need to balance the
books well
a big determinant of that is going to be
looking at the state uh
of growth gross domestic product this
shows you just how fast national income
is increasing in the uk and we know
there was a very big fall in 2020 after
that
uh the expectation is this year the one
we're in at the moment so 2020 that bar
is going to be a lot higher so we'll
update that when the numbers
do come through how much higher it
really depends and of course
that might also determine how much
fiscal consolidation you need to do if
we can go and get back to where we were
before
this crisis hit then you don't need to
do as many tax rises but the uk is worth
saying come over here and have a look
the uk
has had the biggest fall in gdp in 2020
of any
g7 economy it's worth saying these
numbers might well be
revised but for the time being look down
9.9 compared with italy france
canada germany the japan and the us down
by only 3.5
so there'll probably be a lot of
pressure uh to try to get the economy
going again in 2021
and some of that pressure might come
from a bounce back from savings a lot of
people have been saving a lot of money
but here's the thing
the distribution of those savings hasn't
been entirely equal so this breaks down
how much people have been
saving or basically eating into their
savings so anything below the bar is
eating into your savings
by income groups so from the poorest to
the richest and you can see the poorest
have actually dug into their savings
it's not like they've actually built
them up because they've
had quite a tough year this year whereas
the richest they do have a big pile
of savings to spend so how much of that
goes back into the economy and how much
work does the chancellor need to do
well if you compare how much the uk has
done with other countries around the
world here's how things look so this is
fiscal stimulus how much the government
is spending in response to the pandemic
and you can see the uk
that yellow bar is more or less in the
middle of the pack there
but a lot of people will point to the
chancellor towards this
joe biden in the u.s is spending an
extra 1.9
trillion dollars bringing that bar
fiscal stimulus in the u.s
higher than anywhere else we'll bring
you all of these data
as they get updated in the budget it's
going to be fascinating
to see what the chancellor has to say
you're not wrong ed uh we're speaking to
us earlier this hour the former treasury
minister
simon clark said that the chancellor
woods in the budget
set out how the country will once again
begin to live within its means
we're not talking about some some wave
of tax rises that's going to show growth
we are talking however about
a plan that balances strong ongoing
support for the economy
with our leveling up agenda but also
with the beginnings of restoring
credibility to the public finances and i
think you know that is a really
important signal to send those to
investors
but also to the public that we are going
to live uh within our means once more
over the course of you know a reasonable
time horizon and we're going to start
that journey today
joining us now on budget day bridget
phillips and shadow chief secretary to
the treasury miss philips great to have
you on the program
this morning um plenty about the budget
we already know of course so let's
perhaps start in a different way to the
way we usually do
what do you agree with the government on
this morning
well we think some of what they're
likely to announce today and what
they've said already for example on
furlough should have happened months ago
so
there are clearly elements that
businesses and workers have needed
certainty on for a lot longer
so it's disappointing that it's come at
a point where businesses have been
pushed to the edge and we've created
such uncertainty within the economy we
believe the budget that's set out today
must have relentless focus on jobs and
growth to rebuild the foundations of our
economy once more and to get britain
working and moving
with a you know better plan to get young
people into work
and to protect family finances not the
council tax hike that the chancellor is
imposing on local councils at a time
when
we know that families are under such
pressure sure
in terms of a relentless focus on jobs
extending furlough until september that
goes a distance doesn't it
well it's the right thing to do but it
should have happened months ago we've
had such huge uncertainty changes made
with little notice in one case around
furlough with less than six hours to go
until the scheme was due to end that's
no basis on which businesses can make
decisions
about the future and it's part of the
reason that we've taken the biggest hit
of any major economy
uh we've been told by mr clark not to
not to expect a wave of tax rises but
at some point it seems almost inevitable
that there will be some
when they come over the course of the
parliament is a question and where they
come of course i mean
preferably in an ideal world if you were
holding the red box this morning
what would you do we don't think that
now is the right time for tax rises the
economy is in such a fragile position
hitting people in their pockets when we
need to be building up confidence in our
economy
is absolutely essential and the
chancellor is out on a limb on this
mainstream opinion is very clear that
securing the recovery must be the
absolute priority of the government
so that should mean we don't see tax
rises immediately that we see action to
protect family finances because if we
don't see
a strong secure recovery it's going to
make it so much harder into the future
just explain that what is the problem
with tax rises on for example
businesses this morning businesses who
have
run through a pandemic of all things a
profit why would it be wrong to focus
a a very targeted tax rise in those
circumstances on profitable businesses
well firstly we're still in the middle
of a pandemic we're under lockdown
businesses are under enormous pressure
so many are just facing this mountain of
debt
and the chancellor hasn't set out how
he's going to help them but whether it's
the imf or the oecd the most important
point right now
is building up demand within our economy
and confidence not pulling it away
at such a fragile moment so we don't
think that immediate tax rises are the
way to support our economy through this
it will of course make it harder if
we've got fewer people in work
paying taxes and if we've hit people in
their pockets at a point at which we
want them as we start to reopen
to be able to support local businesses i
mean
it is though from from my perspective at
least a little bit of an easy hit for
the labour party today to say you know
look this is not the time
for tax rises all of which suggest that
where are you in government at the
moment there would be tax rises just
not right now i mean when would you uh
consider raising taxes be it in terms of
uh individuals personal income or indeed
on corporation tax
certainly before the end of this
parliament
i mean first of all we need to recognize
that this is a pandemic and it's
unprecedented
secondly it isn't just the labour party
that is saying that now isn't the time
for immediate tax rises everyone from
the cbi to the imf
you'd struggle to find a serious
economist arguing that tax risers are
the way to secure our recovery
we need to see a much greater push on
getting people back into work and on
protecting family finances
not sucking demand out and hitting
people in their pockets at such a
fragile moment
as i said it's quite an easy hit for the
labour party because you get to stand
out as you've just done saying no is not
the time when is the time
well it's true it's it's not a question
of uh of whether it's an easy hit and
the chancellor himself
knows he's playing political games
around this you know he was pressed on
the weekend
about whether he's seeking to raise
taxes now in order to cut them before
the election
that's putting party interest ahead of
our country's best interests right now
that's not a responsible approach it's
not the approach that we would be taking
we need to see that relentless focus on
jobs and growth if we don't see that
if we see tax risers and if we see
demand pulled out of our economy once
more
where we don't protect the universal
credit uplift or we don't support
we don't see the pay protected for our
frontline workers
it will make the recovery far far harder
and that's not what we want to see
i'm going to have another go there is
during this interview being a relentless
focus on reminding people that the
labour party has a relentless focus
on jobs and the economy but when would
you
raise taxes you said you would but you
wouldn't say well you won't say what
we don't want to see tax rises in the
middle of a pandemic i mean to be
absolutely clear it is not the time
that is mainstream opinion that is what
economists are saying it's what the imf
is saying it's not just the labour party
making points around this it's the
chancellor who's outside mainstream
opinion on this
if we don't secure the recovery get
people back to work
it's going to be far far harder so it's
just not the time that's not
just a partnership that i'm making it's
a point that is rooted in the situation
in which we find
ourselves in the middle of a pandemic
having had a deep recession
and under lockdown we shouldn't be
pressing ahead with tax rises
fourth time's a charm assuming that the
road map is stuck to
assuming that things open up on the path
that the government have said on perhaps
with a
tag another month on the end say we come
out not the 21st of june but the 21st of
july
after that point do you think you could
conceive of tax rises
well we hope that the roadmap is
successful we all want to see businesses
reopening once more of course the
government will need to take a longer
term view
about the tax system within our country
but in the immediate short term
do i think that tax rise is a right
right right now no i don't do economists
on the whole absolutely not
does the imf no that is not the
mainstream opinion the chancellor
is setting himself against that in fact
his own business secretary
is arguing that it's not the time for
tax risers and we need to see a focus on
growth
so there is clearly a disagreement
within the government around this
bridget phillipson good to see you this
morning thanks for joining us
thank you uh some
breaking news now are reaching us from
myanmar we're hearing that two people
have been killed at a protest in
mandalay that's according to local
reports
police have been using tear gas to
disperse anti-coup protesters
in several cities and demonstrators have
been using homemade shields and throwing
objects at security forces efforts by
other southeast asian countries to solve
the crisis have
so far stalled we'll bring you a little
bit more on that
later in the program but let's take a
look at a couple of the day's other
big stories now let's head to the united
states where president joe biden says
teachers will be prioritized in the u.s
vaccine rollout
with hopes it will allow classes to
resume with
three vaccines now given approval mr
biden says he's confident the u.s will
have enough
for every adult in the country by the
end of may
all this says that texas governor greg
abbott announces the most
significant lifting of virus
restrictions
including mask wearing and opening most
businesses next week
dolly parton has become the latest
celebrity to urge americans to get
vaccinated
although she's gone at one better in her
bid to let people
to get people to get the jack vaccine
vaccine vaccine vaccine
i'm begging of you please don't hesitate
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
cause once you're dead then that's a bit
too late
she does have a point uh the country
music star donated one million dollars
to vaccine research and
filmed herself getting the injection she
told fans
i'm old enough to get it and i'm smart
enough
to get it
and the love island star molly may er
molly hagan
has been given a warning over social
media promotions
after an 8 000 pound giveaway was found
to be breaking the rules
the advertising standards agency said
the prize draw held to celebrate her
reaching
1 million youtube subscribers wasn't
administered fairly enough
13 people have died after a car carrying
25 people collided with a lorry in
california police say they don't yet
know how the accident happened
most of the seats in the car had been
removed to fit more passengers inside
investigators believe that most of the
people on board were mexican aged
between
15 and 53
and scientists studying sharks say
they've discovered
that three deep sea species glow in the
dark
the researchers working in new zealand
say that whilst it's common in other
marine life
this is the first time they have found
it in these species
rishi zunak is expected to announce more
self-employed people will be eligible
to receive help from the government the
chancellor
has previously been criticized for not
doing enough to support
self-employed workers uh joining us now
stephen gray a freelance cinematographer
and louise kenrick who is
self-employed and works in the event
sector but currently isn't
eligible for government grants uh
morning guys good to see you and a wave
from me as well i saw you saying hello
just over my shoulder there and
i wonder if we can start um with you
louise just just tell us a little bit
about your situation
um you you yourself are self-employed
in the event sector but but newly
self-employed which is of course a hole
that a number of people fell into
absolutely i became self-employed on the
4th of april 2019
having previously been full-time payee
for the last 30 odd years and
suddenly after an amazing year of being
self-employed
earning fantastic money and doing some
great jobs
in a sector that i have to say has
always been very lucrative and very busy
and a massive growth sector for the
economy
um events obviously being one of the
first industries hit
that switched off overnight clients
cancelling events
um things moving virtually and as a
result of that
the focus on the live piece has just
completely fallen by the wayside so
essentially i've now been a year without
any
income from the event sector
and being newly self-employed i fell
down that crack which was great
without being too personal louise and
and go as far as or or
or as close as you like i mean what kind
of effect has this had on your personal
finances i mean how grim are things
right now
it's i mean i've gone from being um
financially stable um and with savings
to
savings being wiped out um that i had my
full tax
pot money set aside to pay a tax bill of
13 000 pounds which i've had to live on
for the last year you know you still
have a mortgage to pay you still have
insurances to pay you still have to put
a roof over your head and live so
that money um you know i'm now in debt
to you know 10 grand and go
and growing because i've still got to
pay a tax bill
um the frustration has been really that
you know with no help it's we'll just go
and get a bounce back loan or just go
and
take this loan out and all that's doing
is just incurring people to get into
debt you know that money still has to be
repaid
and yet we've not been eligible for the
grant system because it
it was deemed oh we're too complicated
they've had a year to sort this out
and it's not good enough you know there
are you know 3.8 million people
like myself through various
circumstances that have paid taxes
that have now fallen through the crack
and it has
not only a dire effect on your financial
state it has a massive
income on your impact on your
self-confidence
on your mental strength and mental state
you know it's just been a
horror of a year in so many ways
um steve steven let's turn to you for a
second you're a freelance
cinematographer we can tell you're the
first guest we've ever had in this
program that knows where to put their
camera
uh before they come on and talk to us so
you understand that i'm only joking
bridget i'm only joking
um sorry let's just tell us though about
how it's been for you i mean you working
you work in extreme environments travel
has has presumably been
massively curtailed over the past year i
mean how's it been for you
well i've been a freelance
cinematographer for about 25 years
i've worked in environments like iraq
bosnia kosovo
antarctica and then been doing pop
videos with escort 7 and various other
people over the years
and obviously when the pandemic occurred
work completely stopped 100 and
i thought okay well clearly there's
going to be some kind of support coming
in for
people like myself but um when richard
student announced the support scheme to
seiss back in march last year and he
introduced what i would consider to be a
very divisive and discriminatory cap
of fifty thousand pounds now
you might say okay fifty thousand 000 is
a decent salary but that is
for tax it is also um doesn't mean
it completely ignores the fact that for
the last year or so
my income has gone down by 80 percent
and
i have a young family which i'm trying
to support
i have a mortgage to pay bills don't go
away
um i don't um qualify for you know
universal credit because of uh savings
in the in the bank for
tax purposes and from my pensions so on
and so forth it just
seems to me to feel like you know we've
been
following through the cracks for about a
year and rishi sunak has done absolutely
nothing
in terms of proper support to help us i
mean i i i see louise nording along um
stephen i mean it must be frustrating
for for the pair of you so
so in turn i mean stephen if you could
get one thing from the chancellor in the
budget today what would it be
it would be partying with uh people
who've been supported in other scenes
and and luis from you what what's the
what's the one measure that
that you're crying out for right now um
well i'm gonna i'm gonna give you two
because one it's a parity as steven says
but equally
we need backdated support people have
had nothing
for a year and in some cases it's
literally killing people and that
is unacceptable just to be completely
neglected you know
the announcements he's expecting to make
today great a step in the right
direction
but for many it's too little too late
and it's not enough
um stephen just the last word from you
we've got about 30 seconds to go you
mentioned of course the kids and
you presumably are at home an awful lot
more at the moment
how's the homeschooling been going i
know i know of course
it's i have to say it's been amazing but
in some ways it's been harder than me on
the front lines
do you know what yeah i think i'd agree
with you on that kind stephen gray uh
louise kenrick
i'll keep my fingers crossed for you
that you at least get some crumbs of
comfort uh brushed from the dispatch box
a little bit later on today but thanks
both
uh for joining us and being so candid